what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation rejoined by Aaron
Alexander how you doing buddy it's been
a long time it's been a spell I am doing
good I'm excited to be back happy to
have you here because what are we
watching today buddy we're watching
Invincible Adam Eve this is a prequel
episode is it season two or is it to the
season one it's in but in between is it
in between her yeah like uh like black
widow all right good Aaron I did not
re-watch Invincible I mean you catch our
reactions to it but we are planning less
I'm planner you plan on planning on
rewatching it before season two comes
out oh yeah officially yeah even though
Amazon listed says season two episode
one yeah we haven't watched that in like
two years
but uh I've got a little bit of a memory
here so guys with that in mind smash
that like button haven't said smashed in
such a long time also be sure to
subscribe and click that notification
Bell to get notified in a few months
when we cover Invincible season two
properly you excited Aaron hella excited
let's swerve from the path of our
regular content to delve into a realm
where Shadow fights light mythical
Champions become the architects of their
own destiny yes you've called it rage
Shadow Legends it's more than just a
name it's an invitation to a symphony of
battles that would make even a dragon
trip in the mystical expanse of Talaria
Darkness looms under the veil reign of
the dark lord siroth Only You Brave
Summoner can conjure an alliance of
Champions to Vanquish this malevolent
force a world teeming with dungeons
formidable adversaries and breathtaking
Landscapes is yearning for a hero from a
legion of over 700 unique Champions
across diverse factions you can craft an
army as unique as a phoenix feather
shape them into an unbeatable force that
will make even the stone golems envious
outfit them with potential artifacts
imbue them with Untold power and let
them unleash their full potential test
your steal against other heroes in the
PVP Arena Battle the great leviathans of
the game World the send the clan
rankings and become the beacon of Glory
in the gloaming The Saga raid is ever
evolving witnessed care of the new
Phantom General akamori whose might
overshadows even the diarist of
nightmares also if the animated series
raid called The Arbiter Escape your gaze
the complete 10 episodes away to an
official rage Shadow Legends YouTube
channel so are you ready to seize a
sword of Destiny and dive into the heart
of Rage Shadow Legends to some of my QR
code or conjure up the link in the
description box to initiate your quest
an epic Champion Drake of the Lizardman
faction along with a horde of other
Treasures awaits you let's weave our
Legends together so don't forget light
the way by hitting my link in the
description box or the QR code on screen
and I'll see you in the Twilight of the
battlefield as the Arbiter watches over
us may you always find Victor
[Music]
oh man we saw the first season oh my God
on a little computer monitor remember
that we've come so far we're fighting
conquer we'll find this room faster if
we split up no my son that's not a
tactically sound strategy one of those
lizard people we need to stay together
what Mom Prince lizard
[Laughter]
just straightforward name yeah our intel
was spotty but the serum should be on
this level the Flames of this Burning
world will warm are cold blood onward
until the lizard leave oh boy the lizard
League love the alliteration
the Guardians
the Guardians of the globe
oh so this is like an actual prequel
this is a prequel yeah
[Music]
this doesn't have to get any uglier than
it already is it's like they're taking
the serpent Society is that what they're
doing here
sure about that God I did miss the show
I was just thinking the same thing this
reminds me of the the season premiere
though except in reverse
you better
you better than hire goal is that black
Samsung don't waste your time Samson oh
it is Darkwing not coming down still
healing after the corona dial Battle Red
Rush
busy in Russia and Martian man's helping
dark blood on some important Mission
dark blood was that the the demon guy
yeah nice this feels so much like a DC
animated movie oh yeah totally
[Music]
do they live I don't know
oh Omni man Big Daddy stash new suit
yeah the tailor said it wasn't iconic
enough
apparently everyone's running around
with a big letter on their chest these
days he's looking at me
and you won't do for two more weeks I'm
sorry Dr brandyworth I know how
important this baby is oh is that Adam
Eve I should have found another one [__]
some kind of telepath aren't you yeah oh
they're getting closer we have to get
you to a hospital yeah this has to be
years before I took it because yeah uh
Samson has bald head in the present she
was literally born like pretty much on
the battlefield of the Guardians wow
yeah so sorry I did this to you feels
like The Stranger Things scientists
totally yeah papa we're headed for the
Valley Hospital a child is too valuable
to leave her birthday
we have a hospital I just realized we
don't see her mom in the show bring up
bring up you'll get your weapon and in
the end you'll thank me for it
classic that voice on the phone sounds
so familiar who is that I don't know
also You Gotta Throw your phone out the
window sits at the media staple you must
be ready for any other
now it's probably worth more protection
you know like
you really cared about her
look cut it out cut it up section
C-section C-section let's go let's go
see that [__]
cut that belly
find me the buddies oh maybe this
special is about him trying to find her
again oh
like stranger things like Papa yeah
Mr and Mrs Wilkins you want this one
who thought she was gone but take it she
came back to us
ah switcheroo
Sam sure loves her Legos huh it's the
only thing she'll play with
good Easter egg
any idea why Mercury is a liquid at room
temperature when it's surrounded by
solids my
they got a bond Robert Oppenheimer
[Laughter]
Killian Murphy
Sam's been making molecules for me check
it out that's baking soda this one is
glucose and believe it or not that's
magnesium
I'll punch this guy
oh science in my goddamn house
she could barely read it all she has
these molecules memorized like she could
just see them in her head get out of my
house
[Laughter]
he's 16. for all we know he made it all
up if he was a white kid I would take
this news differently
[Laughter]
that's the last time we let it colored
in the house
grossy now concentrate on maintaining
your form is that just like his muscle
fibers oh yeah I don't like it
is that what's his name oh Jesus is that
the little baby guy the the robot oh
maybe hi I'm Samantha Wilkins right I
guess you know I'm the weirdo that lives
across the street from you oh wait
you're just smart girl that's what my
mom said I'm bow the even weirder weirdo
who lives across the street from you
it's about part of the Teen Titans group
she was a part of I don't think so
you've got homework to do if you want to
get your grades up my grades are great
your mother and I were told you were
special how silly us we thought that
meant you should go to a school for
special kids why is this guy like the
biggest [__] in the world they don't
have any fun or care about anything
they're just a bunch of freaks they're
freaks look at yourself isn't that why
you belong there
ouch damn dad what is your problem
she knows like I don't know I don't know
man you've been a dick this whole
episode
you kind of meant that
here it is
yeah
science
science [__]
[Music]
she's like seeing things on a molecular
level oh
turn to class
wow that's cool
sell them at an art museum make money
change back change back change
that's cool it's kind of broken kind of
a op power if you ask me I made you a
snack sweetie cream cheese and Olive
sandwich
what
you had that [__]
that [__] no
don't play with your food
that's what I'm talking about so I'm
talking about Adam Eve keep playing with
your food never stop spearmint right
now it's Cherry try it oh no
she reacted to her powers very well
right
Sam I'm serious how are you doing this
she is not reacting to her friend's
Powers very well
not taking it wow I can make stuff I've
heard stuff
[Music]
thought it was fun it's not okay it's
freaking scary you're a freak
I should go home now wait big ass friend
Val
oh that's your one and only friend
he's my friend I said let's make some
weird [__] yeah man dude if you give me
superpowers I'd be jealous let's drink
all the ginger ale we want to be like
get me some G fuel
oh pink it's your favorite color
thing is pink like her outfit remember
to write a thank you note to Aunt Penny
is that Anne penny Penn Easter egg
that'll be totally missed I don't know
better fits let's go
do not hurt that animal make it a Super
Squirrel I wish you were a puppy make it
talk
I wish I had a puppy
she makes a puppy out of thin air
oh dude you're you've become a homeless
man yo yo you're stinky
yo
put it on your face
my God it's gonna be a first night out
on the town
that's fun nice runs you have static
shock that's exactly what I was thinking
oh
look at her brain her powers to life
she's like a cooler Miss Marvel yeah
totally yeah
ah what the hell
no Powerpuff girl shut up you shut up
shut up buzz off Powerpuff come on we
need to get the rest imagine what I can
do to those dumb masks you're wearing
oh damn
oh my God just the weight of that you're
gonna leave them squirming like turtles
on their backs don't come any closer
don't worry how did you get there so
fast Adam and Betsy Wilkins are not your
real parents I'm adopted man that would
explain a lot
my name is Dr Elias brandyworth I was
the assistant director of the pentagon's
Department of superhuman research
research you eat out of dumpsters yeah
just stay off the grid to protect you
you were one of my projects cement now
give him some food Samantha all right
he's giving you valuable information
you're crazy I'm leaving you could see
molecules turn paper into stone feel the
chemical composition of the world in
your bones he knows what he's talking
about make me a nice steak dinner out of
some leaves yeah please can you make
some cash for me please I'm so hungry
then why come find me now the military
thinks you're dead if they discover
you're not they'll come for you yeah
shut this [__] down stop using them no I
I can do things that matter I can help
people I'm begging you not to conceal
don't feel what's that noise what noise
you have to go it's already begun do not
use your powers go even if the military
comes for you don't defend yourself
father and I have done everything for
you sent you to a special school look
the other way with these odd little
habits of yours I hate her parents
just be normal that's not what I said I
love you Samantha I do but I wish you'd
try harder sometimes great parenting
guys I feel like they they so Overlook
just the caliber of Genius that she is
every parent we've killed to have a
child this morning we sent a drone out
after our sensors got paid guaranteed
and not become a prostitute down the
road you know
I don't care about science you care
about
industrial work playing into the
patriarchy stay in your your lane girl
are we closed have you seen him are you
sure he isn't here oh yes I look twice
he's not here he's he's by the dumpsters
did he not tell you
look behind your local Applebee's be
right there way to not use your powers
good job you listen great you I'm gonna
go way up in the sky you understood the
assignment clearly nice soul patch bro
makes your face extra punchable
get out of my way kid cut his head off
once you give that all back and sit down
nicely and wait for the police the names
kill cannon not gets beat up by little
girls cam have you seen this guy before
he seems familiar right I'll know on my
re-watch
what
the hell kick his ass
we can just change his Cannon to
something else
kill him you should literally never have
to throw a punch ever she could just
change his gun yeah yeah exactly you're
just not made for this
great job
whoa
whoa Samantha man did you get more
disheveled bro how did you show up told
you to be by the trash cans what you
don't even take a day off on your
birthday how do you know it's my
birthday my parents didn't even remember
damn those parents are worthy
you have a super genius and you don't
appreciate her that's cool treat you a
burger for some answers oh thank God
it's been waiting for she's buying him a
burger just make him a burger
she was a valued colleague she
volunteered her pregnancy for an
experimental procedure oh interesting we
manipulated her amniotic fluid induced
controlled mutational change and I was
making a terrible mistake that's all she
would have wanted for you a normal life
I like this scientist character yeah too
bad he's definitely gonna die a hundred
percent
I'm wearing a mask I'm using a fake name
I'm apparently a government-designed
super weapon I'll be fine now how is the
government still not after you in
present day that's what I want to know
I'm
just going to wipe out this operation
former perimeter or something what get
the hell out of here
dope sauce
[Music]
oh you're nasty
I kind of got a little something hanging
out your your face there
[Music]
kurosi gross gross gross oh melty I have
to speak for our siblings they've never
been out of their tanks long enough to
learn to talk our siblings it's kind of
tragic phase two phase three Base Four
phase five
less successful than the last but all
one big happy family they're your
siblings oh so like Weapon X but like
worse or like 11 from stranger things
yeah yeah
[Music]
guys
there's the blood there's that
Invincible violence
[Music]
how did she become such a good fighter
right
certainly she's been no more crime than
we were saying solving fighting more
crime
this action is great
what disturbing body horror would that
phase two guy
oh
you can't like change their molecules
and stuff too you can't heal them
we are reaching Man of Steel territory
[Music]
oh you can't heal your own wounds
sweet
cool very cool thank you
our cave again
let's go iron Eve
[Music]
oh God damn
so creative it's like Miss Marvel and
Green Lantern in one I was just saying
the same thing
[Music]
oh my God I mean it's so envious
what cool choreography
ah Man of Steel Man of Steel
you're making it worse you're just
making it worse
there's a family in there
nice hell yeah
that's the Man of Steel I'm looking for
Heroic side of making sure to protect
the people
wouldn't that have been nice then why
didn't keep trying to attack her you
started this Randy worth he's not our
family we're the best they could make
without him you should get Brandon worth
involved all we hear is how perfect you
are and how perfect we are
that's not her fault
ouch why don't you like subdue them and
just like try to talk to him for a
second
laughs
oh brandyworth
you actually like this monster good
oh the impact of that still could have
that didn't save him he's old I think oh
it did thank you still not making out of
it prevent you from altering living
tissue
break past your subconscious barrier
ah
look at me yeah hey body horror is so
disturbing oh my God
oh
I wish everything was different for us
sure yeah
Samantha we have Samantha
Brandy was
what a treat son of a [__] son of a
stash it's time to bring it all down
break past your subconscious barrier let
him go and
we are playing
all right guys come on but now that I
have Brenda with his research partner
isn't needed anymore are you sure do it
what
it's like a mom who who is that where do
you think all your brothers and sisters
came from oh [__]
ah good old mom oh God technically alive
we didn't get her back up and running in
time to save her from mess and bring it
get out my face bro come on now you
monster
nah man
don't freaking die
oh no the mom
heal her
this poor woman oh my gosh it's been
through so much
[Music]
oh great it's getting off camera death
ray what the hell so lame
you were murdered
Scarlet witchton right I could rearrange
yourselves to make you whole new people
from the monsters
she's Dr Manhattan okay cool
I am Samantha
and remember who I am
[Music]
happened
she broke free and prosper limits
but it wasn't her perspective since
they've done I was locked into her
perspective the whole time yeah what
where am I well a bit farther
oh she actually took a Kinder path to it
huh yeah
oh God
and where have you been Adam wait don't
stick up for her [__] a you couldn't
even call get that stick out your ass
give me my cake wow
laughs
that's sad oh that's really sad please
please come out
happy birthday let's try again that's so
sad
only one I've got I get it man you gotta
settle for what you got I got jabby KOA
on the internet
it's all going to be okay I promise
wow wow I thought they were gonna like
go to the par where we catch up to her
age right I thought they're gonna go
present day
all this oh oh we're doing it yes
um you're home early yeah light day Dad
look I'm gonna be duct tape man
that boy is never getting his powers is
he don't ask me you're the superhero
space alien but even if he doesn't I
will love him just as much no I won't
you're just my pet I don't even love you
oh that Sinister look what are you so
mad for
she needs to make sure his son gets
Powers oh right right
wow
wow she's conflicted man wow the range
of emotion that man's face I know JK
Simmons performed that well with no
dialogue right there yeah man the
animated the show JK said
all right man all right oh what a great
time to return to the world of
invincible I really enjoyed that I
enjoyed that a lot I enjoyed that a lot
Aaron what did you think laid your
thoughts down later honest thoughts down
about what you liked what you didn't
like as I get readjusted here shake it
out let's get readjusted here all right
what'd you like oh man I liked it all I
did not expect this to be a prequel if I
didn't watch any trailers or anything
going into this it said the first
sentence is in this special prequel
episode you'd go in blinds you said this
is an in-betweekual like you knew what
you were talking about I mean prior to
today
prior to the moments we sat down I had
no clue but
yeah I thought it was really effective
in us really getting to see behind the
scenes of what our childhood is like
gonna get more informed I wonder if they
did this because we're gonna see a lot
more of that backstory kind of continue
to the present day of season two sure so
we can kind of like really get invested
with her and it's they made this
something that's like non-essential at
least from what we know so far but I
think it's going to add a lot of flavor
and uh peppering into the season uh
hopefully it plays back into it but yeah
I thought the stuff with
um her find her found family or the
people she would choose to be really
compelling you know like she had a
really shitty life and that kind of that
really sucks but I think that
yeah I think we got to see
what makes her her and the fact that you
know she cares so much and it's like
she's this girl that
has
these powers that wants to help people
but also kind of doesn't know who she is
but she's like way smarter than everyone
else around her we don't feel like she
fed in and she finally at the end found
people that were of her kin you know and
I think that was very very cool and cool
cool yeah but yeah I thought the action
was really good I thought the music was
really good um it made me miss
invincible and kind of remember what the
show is really about you know it
balances that action with the heart and
it succeeds well at what it does I think
from a marketing standpoint which is not
the first thing I expected to talk about
I think from a marketing standpoint it's
actually kind of Genius because it takes
place before season one and other than
uh the stuff with Omni man it's not
really trying to do these attempts to
you know fill in like specif like yes
they were always alluding to uh Adam
Eve's backstory and and then we saw that
you know I think an invincible season
one she ends up running away from from
her home she did yeah yeah but it's what
happens right
but this still can serve as a
this like this this perfectly segues you
into doing a re-watch yeah you know what
I mean because it's been a few years so
people odds are there's probably gonna
be a lot of people who are gonna have to
re-watch they said they released this a
few months before season two comes out
so it is a great way to encourage people
to go oh actually this is a an awesome
segue into going back into re-watching
uh season one and then we can watch
season two when it comes out I think
that was like really smart and I I
really thought this was great because
you know prior to I liked I remember
liking Adam Eve but
I mean at least for I think a lot of
people she was you know the main talk
was always like Market on me man right
right and then I I know that a lot of
people really loved her uh but the main
thing that people when you look back on
Invincible is those two characters
so with her and knowing about the
special I didn't know about it until you
texted me uh saying there's a new
special and I was like yeah we should
watch it and
I was like yeah I'm interested because
it's Invincible but I I'm not like hyper
curious about it but this certainly
quickly instilled of vast appreciation
for her character that I don't quite
recall having prior that makes me
excited to do the re-watch so that way
I'm all this knowledge and emotional
Association is now going to be applied
when watching that Journey
because here what was neat was that
it wasn't like Ultra gory and it didn't
exactly you know Break The Rules or
break the boundaries in the way how you
know the first season of invincible did
in a lot of ways it was a darker Bolder
and more experimental version of a
of an origin story yeah you know like
and for for the most part I was like oh
this is about like a
the origin story by the numbers as you
might expect it to go when you just look
at the outline of stuff like the death
of the scientist was predictable and the
way she was discovering her powers and
whatnot and and the Wonder and then
saving people and then towards like the
last
um 10 to 15 minutes of this is when I
thought like oh they developed a really
unique wrap around for it I'm not saying
it wasn't unique in original throughout
like they were peppering in those unique
original elements consistently you know
and it had a bit of that stranger things
tone that we were talking about and I
appreciated also to the the ability to
do a lot with a little where you don't
really spend too much time with these
brothers but when they're there it's
really effective and you could feel the
torture that they went through you know
uh the the anguish that they there's a
word for doing a lot with a little and I
can't quite pull it right now but I
remember writing it down and I don't
know
but uh what the hell is it laconic is
that the word
I think it's laconic laconic you would
know you looked the word up
I don't know I've been doing a lot with
a little huh like um because it's it's
it it didn't I didn't leave this going
this should have been longer no no I
think it used its run time very well it
was an hour long it's like 50 something
like 52 minutes or so 50 something 52
minutes I went by fast yeah there was
very well there are a couple things that
I do wish that they did Implement though
like in the end I didn't walk away going
I wish this was longer I think of course
with a longer run if it's like an hour
and a half probably would have been in
tears by the end with the way how some
of the stuff played out could have had
more Breathing Room in certain elements
of course of course it did I think
though again I'm thinking about the
marketing side of it that I don't think
as many people would tune in for an hour
and a half of course there are those
people I'm just saying I don't feel like
most people you think you're gonna get
more people to tune in for a 52 minute
one that just feels like a regular
episode versus in like an hour and a
half special
um but yeah like her her ability to use
the powers I think would have been kind
of a cool part of the origins hail to
explore I actually got good at fighting
because she became like incredibly good
at fighting is that just part of her
skill set
maybe I mean she she learned
she's learned a lot really quickly
um yes yeah man I feel like that's like
a common like superhero Trope though
they learn really quickly without doing
much training so I think legitimately
yeah except that as like part of the
conceit of the story yeah yeah now I was
able to get on board with it but I I
think that is something that still would
have helped just enhance it myself
really what it is is like there are
things that just if it was longer it
could have just enhanced it
yeah you know it's always good to have
more time to flesh things out you know I
think that it achieved what it set out
to do from the very beginning that I
think like
even like the seeds of what this thing
had uh had set up you see through from
what they've [__] it's been two years
but when I remember of invincible like
this whole thing of like finding a place
to belong into and like her not feeling
comfortable within her family and she
she had this family that she discovered
very late in the game when she got her
powers but then like within the show the
proper show proper she has this found
family of like the superhero team the
Guardians
and then she has some work she found a
sense of a friendship sense of kinship
and I think that's kind of been her
journey through this whole thing like
realizing her own potential in addition
to realizing where she kind of fits into
things what I didn't okay if there's
something I didn't really like about the
execution of this is
it's the it's the uh the parents I get
your I guess there's no Nuance really
exactly that's the exact word there's no
Nuance the mom is like
you know I'm disciplining you know I'm
sorry what happened to you uh Matt oh
what happened to you and the dad's
always like you're a [__]
it's the constantly them there's and I
get it you're not supposed to be likable
they're emotionally abusive uh I I
understand the intention I do think the
execution though even even in like a
domestically violent situation it can be
they're gonna be Nuance to
to the levels of why they treat them the
way why they treat her the way they do
or you know seeing that other seeing
that there might be more of a conflict
of why she does ultimately still chew
let's just goes through like the
territor's like Yeah The Experience is
murder and crazy violence like she's
already at a point like you can go but
she's just a child and you know she's
got these emotional attachments and
stuff and I'm like at the same time
though she's she's got a significantly
more experiences than your average child
and I could totally see her like why did
you go off on her own way earlier than
where she goes off on the show
um because there is no there's nothing
here to make me go I can see though as
tough as her dad is
I also see why she loves her dad yeah
especially knowing that she's adopted by
them you know like I and I got none of
those Shades other than other than the
Montage when she's a child of like hey
look we're getting along but as far as
their actual relationship goes I really
do think it lacked um like it's like I
don't even call like a single scene
it didn't take anything big either you
could have had something like really
small like maybe her dad like going to
knock on her door but like walking away
or something or like feeling like a they
sort of like a little bit of a sense of
shame but yeah it would have gotten more
and private though yeah in private
exactly like not so necessarily she had
to see but yeah I'm trying can't
remember if there's any Nuance within
the parent characters within the the
actual show but I think it definitely
needed some for sure because you know I
either want her to like get entirely out
of that situation or you know maybe her
parents come to some sense of of clarity
or some sense of light realizing like
they've been so shitty to their daughter
you know like maybe they can impair
their relationship but I take it that's
probably not what's going to happen but
yeah something else I would like to see
is like a more
connected point to where we are in the
show like a glimmer of hope that she
does find like a sense of community and
finds a sense of
of uh promise or hope beyond the
scenario which you just came into you
know like maybe she meets some of the
heroes that she's on a team with you're
gonna meet her in episode two of
invincible she's already part of the
team I was like okay I would have liked
to see like some sort of how she became
part of the because there's a teen what
I forgot the name of it the teen team or
something like that yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah also why she went from like
wearing a mask to not wearing a mask I
didn't get that either I should have
learned that and how she and how she met
her who is her boyfriend uh Rex I think
Rex yeah yeah
I mean we I guess we don't really need
to see all that I think it was really
cool to actually keep it
I feel like it would be cool like a part
two of the special if anything because I
think what they decided to focus on for
this specific chapter of her life is is
really compelling stuff like even when
we were talking about stranger things
the scientists is like a nicer flip on
Dr Brenner yeah you know oh he was a
scientist like oh I actually messed up
here I'm sorry I didn't even look after
you right instead of just trying to uh
hone in on what you are and make you a
an awesome weapon yeah you know that I
sickly love at the same time I like the
way they I like their relation I like
that character
um and I liked how they kept everything
in the perspective and also the
potential like oh maybe maybe this is
someone who can help in the fight
against because in season one when it
ended it was a Seth Rogen character and
he was saying that more of omnimance
people are coming yeah yeah yeah the the
vulture might something like that Victor
victory yeah and then yeah Victory
Boulevard yeah
the sweet sweet victory yes uh yeah
they're coming and you see how oh maybe
she does but then again everyone seems
like they have potential but no I mean
she's got this like
because they do have that tease about if
she can unlock what's in that
subconscious she might have the ability
to actually rival some of the power sets
here yeah
Lantern and Miss Marvel on the one and
and uh Dr Manhattan and Dr Manhattan
yeah yeah so wait did she go to that
Supernova state in the show proper I
can't remember no idea okay because I
think it's interesting if she did or if
she hasn't yet that could be a potential
tease for things to come that we haven't
seen just yet I imagine they were the
entire comic book is done neither of us
have read the comics we don't know what
what is to come so please don't spoil it
but
um yeah yeah we gotta like not read the
comments yeah but comment and leave your
thoughts down below because it helps the
video out but yeah
yeah yeah I'm curious I'm curious but
don't tell me if this is in the comics
or not or there's something strictly
written for the show as like a little
additional uh thing to add flavor into
uh what we're about to watch in season
two yeah I thought it was interesting
because I from the poster or from like
the thumbnail it made it seem like it
was going to start with her childhood or
her like Origins and then like lead into
whatever season two to tease but this
was entirely took place in the past so
theoretically you could just watch this
prior to starting Invincible exactly and
just like go in that's exactly yeah I
mean no I mean it's just the thing when
you when you get to her and Invincible
it it it informs you at the background
you just don't see how some of these
relationships started but it informs you
of it yeah yeah see and this this is
giving you a backstory that they only
tease about being born in a lab and
stuff like that or scientist experiment
uh but as far as the story itself I
thought it was paced really well and
there's it's tragic I love how tragic it
is that is my that's the thing that
truly separates in it as well from just
your typical origin story is just how
freaking Bleak it gets you know and as
some stuff feels a bit rushed over like
oh the mom returning uh being in that
chamber like again in a longer run time
would have helped enhance these moments
and could have brought to things like
I'm freaking crying right now is that
that could have that could have had room
for some truly compelling moments but I
had a stronger Punch Yeah yeah a lot of
things could have uh in that regard but
I can't say like I was disappointed by
the end and the and I'm not just being
nice about it like I'd be honest with
you if I was like man what the [__] but
the the but that the whole storyline I
think was uh was truly something
like so messed up and and I like how
messed up it ended like sometimes origin
sales they do end on a note that has a
and some type of all those loss that
really helps to find the characters sure
but this is just like knockout after
knockout to This Girl's Life or identity
and then coming to a home where it
doesn't even end on a cliche note of oh
but I have my family here like no these
guys are messed up you know like this
does not feel like home to her so it
just ends on the darkest of notes and
then you cut to Mark's life which looks
like the perfect family but no that's
actually the truly Sinister one so I
like the mirroring of that yeah you know
so yeah I thought it was great man I
thought it was great yeah yeah maybe you
couldn't watch this before because like
the Omni man told emotional range and
you go and like what's that about that's
like it's like it's like 30 seconds
but you could just be like what does
that mean what's the tease of what yeah
but it doesn't give any exact detail or
anything yeah yeah alrighty guys well
what did you think about this special
leave your thoughts down below keep a
lookout for when we cover Invincible
season two
um subscribe follow Aaron you could
catch us on patreon and we will talk
with you all soon ladies and gentlemen
thank you for being here
thank you